[Musique]
aujourd'hui on parle de la nouvelle you
get book de lenovo je sais pas si vous
avez vu il ya un an et demi à peu près
je vous avais présenté la première yoga
book de lenovo
on peut l'utiliser de différentes
manières et ça c'est vraiment
intéressant
il y en a en tout quatre ça je vous
avait déjà présenté pas pour faire un
topo dessus et la lenovo a présenté à
l'ifa 2018 une toute nouvelle version de
sa yoga book qui reste dans la même
direction mais qui programme un petit
virage parce que la première yoga book
vous pouviez d'avoir soit sur android
soit sur windows 10 là vous n'avez plus
que sur windows 10 vous aviez une petite
zone vous pouvez utiliser votre stylo
autre style et qui servent également de
claviers la cette zone là est devenu un
écran enfin vous allez voir c'est yoga
book
elle est sûr booster on peut faire plus
de choses l'inconvénient c'est coûtent
aussi beaucoup plus cher mais par contre
elle a un petit peu changé l'adn
avant c'était une tablette qui pouvait
être un ordinateur aujourd'hui c'est un
ordinateur qu'on peut aussi utiliser un
version tablette c'est un point de
détail mais ça change un peu la donne
je vous la montre première chose à faire
enlever ça voilà alors voyons voir ce
soit un petit peu comme la première
version petite languette on tire on
l'avait yoga book
alors là on ouvre en plusieurs parties
ici on a la partie secteur blog de
charge ces sorties pour l'autre côté ça
c'est carrément éjecté on va donc une
recherche qui se fait en usb type c'est
le bloc de charge qui hélas ici qu'est
ce qu'on a
quick start dit denis lequel de quoi
ouvrir votre petit tiroir pour rester
votre carte microsd est-ce qu'on peut
effectivement être une carte de micro sd
pour les jusqu'à 512 giga de stockage
on a ensuite ici le style et commence à
s'ouvrir
cool toujours très très classe le modèle
de l'année dernière on avait soit la
partie avec la mine qui roule dessus
donc qui n'écrit pas et on avait le
petit stylo est-ce que c'est toujours la
même chose ah non la station de 40 pile
d'accord donc là c'est vraiment un
produit qui est complètement différent
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
franchement je préfère vraiment cet
emballage à celui des dernières il était
pas mal mais là c'est quand même
vachement plus classe le bleu choisi est
super jolie le côté un peu ardoise
grafite d'un côté vraiment créatif très
sympa logo lenovo une partie avec un
dégradé bleu violine qui est très joli
stock que là dessus ils ont vraiment
c'est un super boulot
lenovo soit packaging on peut mettre le
style et la roque et voilà cémenté il ya
une nouvelle fonction qui est hyper cool
doble rock ni to open
ok on va regarder ça juste après j'aime
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup je trouve
plus cavic celui de l'année dernière
beaucoup plus joli bond la charnière est
toujours très sympa un côté très très
robuste on a ici port usb type c les
haut-parleurs ici vous allez pouvoir
votre extension de quartier face à la
version wifi mais il existe aussi une
version vous pouvez rajouter une carte
nanosims pour vous connecter en 4g donc
ça va à paris si bon ici la charnière
vous avez ici encore de l'usb type c il
faut savoir qu'il se recharge en usb
type c'est ici des petits boutons est
ici également le haut parleur
[Musique]
discover du display bolt iriti wayne
rooney double écran vous avez l'écran
principal qui est là c'est du quad hd
deuxième écran full hd
on va le regarder d'ici quelques
instants assez drôle d'avoir cet écran
là ça me change vraiment par rapport à
celle que j'avais avant où vous aviez un
côté qu'un vous voyez vous deviez en
tout cas le clavier là on va plus du
tout c'est un écran et là vous avez le
capteur d'empreintes digitales ici pour
venir des droïdes j'aime beaucoup pour
que vraiment il on l'est encore plus
loin alors c'est pareil à la charnière
ça ça n'a pas bougé
ça se fait extrêmement bien c'est hyper
flexible s'appelle pas yoga pour rien ça
c'est vraiment hyper hyper calitom
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup de
produits sauf que il fait vraiment un
côté très très très robuste n'avait pas
du tout ni top l'effet qu'il n'y a rien
c'est bien ça tient bien et du coup vous
allez voir il ya plein d' usage avec ge
pas si vous vous souvenez de la yoga
book de l'année dernière c'était
franchement en appareils différents
ça c'est drôle de retrouver un peu cet
appareil mais de le voir vraiment en ont
complètement différent parce que l'année
dernière lorsque vous ouvrirez votre
chat book vous aviez ici complètement
différent c'est très très drôle vous
retrouviez ici un clavier qu'on pourrait
deviner même lorsqu'il est éteint et
vous avez un petit bloc notes avec des
vraies feuilles dessus vous posiez bloc
notes
il était aimanté et vous aviez un crayon
avec deux types de mines une première
mine un peu mou ce qu'elle vous allez
destinée sur la partie clavier mais qui
était pas un écran n'est pas eu tout à
l'écran et vous pouviez dessinée
effectivement sans votre parti
bloc-notes 32 mode dessine et faire ce
que vous vouliez se permettait d'avoir
des notes qui était à la fois numérisés
et à la pomme pourrait les prendre et
vous avez omis papier avec cette année
ils ont vraiment fait le chemin inverse
lenovo en disant on va supprimer le bloc
notes on a supprimé le bout de papier
on va tout faire de façon numérique du
coup on a une salle mines
on a un crayon avec une pile intérieur
et on a un deuxième partie ici qui en
fait un écran lcd
parce que pour rentrer un peu au niveau
des specs vous avez deux écrans de 10,8
pouces de chaque côté l'écran principal
à une résolution de 2560 par 1600 pixels
et le deuxième est un écran full hd 1920
par 1080 les deux sont des écrans lcd
sont des dalles ip est ce là la
résolution forcément est beaucoup plus
élevé
qualité elle se situe ici mais néanmoins
c'était cran là une vraie belle
fonctionnalités qui est vraiment bien
lorsque vous allez être de survoler
liseuse je vous expliquais après tout ça
lorsque vous allez 200mo liseuse vous
allez consommer beaucoup moins d'énergie
et c'est un vrai hybrides parce que vous
l'utilisez comme ça en mode pc un petit
peu standard vous l'utiliser comme ça
pour regarder un film une série est ce
que vous voulez vous l'utiliser comme ça
ça nous fait une liseuse pour lire un
bouquin
voilà peut vraiment l'utiliser comme
vous voulez et fait vraiment tout l'adn
de cette chaudière à l'intérieur vous
avez un processeur intel core i5 de
septième génération 4 gigas de ram lp
ddr3 vous avez un ssd de 256 gigas milly
extensible avec une carte micro sd que
vous allez mettre exactement ici jusqu'à
512 jega ça c'est vraiment cool côté
graphique c'est une intel hd graphics
615 vous avez une batterie de 4650
millions père arc donné jusqu'à tout
près 8 heures d'autonomie et en mode
liseuse vous avez jusqu'à 13 heures
d'autonomie ça tourne sur windows dix
familles vous avez du wifi bien
évidemment du bluetooth 4.2 zidi 100%
usb type c'est la recharge se fait en
usb tisser et forcément si vous voulez
branche autre chose et il faudra un
petit dock je conseille de prendre un
dock de voyage comme ça vous branchez
vous avez tout ce que vous voulez usb
type pas de la hd est bien plus que vous
voulez toujours en plus de ça ce qui est
cool c'est pour l'ouvrir il suffit de
taper il ya quelqu'un et là ils sont
bons ces gadgets en dessous soit
vraiment vraiment drôle vous avez ici un
capteur d'empreintes digitales pour
venir à l'allumer directement qui marche
super bien il me reconnaît il
déverrouillait directement l'écran ici
vous allez franchement une qualité qui
est vraiment très très très très bien
vous avez windows et l'eau pour
déverrouiller avec notre connaissance de
votre visage
l'accord tanabe moi c'est un windows
s'agit pas vous expliquer comment ça
marche vous voyez l'écran là il est
franchement hyper cool et là vous avez
un tout petit rouge trouverez pied tous
à vous servir à ouvrir le pavé tactile
avoir une donne un peu plus grande et
vous allez voir les différents votes
sont franchement cool alors si on se
concentre que sur cette petite partie
clavier c'est vraiment cool et c'est
très très très impressionnant déjà on a
un vrai retour regardez le niveau des
touches lorsqu'on appuie dessus on a une
vraie sensation de retour il ya un
retour haptique ça ça marche bien
la up je vais fermer mon mode menu je
vais l'ouvrir ici ça va donc tout
m'ouvrir donc là c'est la partie clavier
là c'est la partie prise de notes
j'adore cet effet voyez je dessine très
très bien je quitterais très bien
vous allez appuyer ici sur le plus hot
pour créer une nouvelle note bon comme
ça on part un peu de la base je vous
montrais rapidement le but pas de vous
montrer comment dessiner avec parce que
je suis un très très mauvais dessinateur
et puis franchement j'en suis incapable
je vais vous faire un petit un petit
message un petit coucou noyer même là
j'ai l'impression de bien écrire lorsque
je vais utiliser mon stylo s'est appuyé
par exemple sur le bouton du bas ça me
fait une gomme passion on le voit bien
là comme ça mais j'ai mon message que
j'avais écrite sous qui reste un petit
peu de sou qu'on continue à voir c'est
pas du tout un bug c'est juste pour
pouvoir reprendre des choses et d'avoir
un petit peu sur quoi on était fous ça
vraiment bien donc je peux vous réécrire
un petit coucou à peu près au même
endroit ce que j'avais fait avant c'est
vraiment cool ça glisse vraiment bien
dessus
bon après il ya pas mal d'options vous
allez sur les 1000 vous avez différentes
épaisseurs de très près de plus je ne
suis pas un graphiste donc c'est pas moi
qui vous ai déjà plus là dessus ça c'est
la gauche aussi sans avoir à cliquer sur
le bouton ça n'a fait une capture
d'écran de ce que j'ai en eau et voyez
je vais le retrouver ici et là ce que je
lis ensuite déplacé je peux venir
travailler donc sur la prise de notes
sur des éléments je travaillais sur mon
écran supérieur pouvoir le retrouver en
bas ensuite ici je veux voir une zone de
sélection de textes donc la voyez j'ai
sélectionné une partie est là je vais
pouvoir copier copier en tant qu'image
en tant que texte en tant que formulaire
en tant que schéma ce que je veux donc
ça s'écoule ensuite hop
ici je reviens en arrière je retourne de
l'autre côté et ici j'ai un truc qui
coule
c'est cette fonction là ça me permet de
dessiner avec le doit venir dessiner
avec mon doigt je peux dire écrire avec
mon doigt vous voyez j'écris tout aussi
bien avec mon doigt mais ça c'est rigolo
parce que si on veut travailler un peu
manuellement voyez on peut bien le faire
directement avec son doigt et je vous
dis avec cette fonction le style et ne
marche plus du tout donc ça c'est pour
la partie note
ensuite je viens ici l'âge et la partie
liseuse donc à un peu comme un kindle en
gros si vous voulez vous allez pouvoir
prendre des pdf vous allez pouvoir les
lire directement dessus c'est cool c'est
beaucoup plus reposant que l'autre écran
de l'autre côté et l'a ensuite j'ai tous
mes réglages
moi j'adore ce mode vous avez tous vos
petits réglages à l'intérieur pour le
clavier hic vous allez pouvoir
paramétrer vos images tapoter pofalla ya
quelques petits réglages qui sont assez
cool
j'aime bien je trouve que c'est assez
bien pensé l'année dernière je l'aimé
bien là yoga books a trouvé assez
intéressante mais je trouve qu'avec
cette partie là ça rajoute encore mais
fonctionnel et en plus envie d'aller
loin au niveau de la prise de notes
c'est écolo ça évite de gâcher du papier
et ça c'est franchement plutôt pas mal
c'est assez green au chu de galles le
style et fonctionne bien je trouve qu'il
ya vraiment du détail alors après une
fois de plus n'étant pas un graphiste
moi même j'en appelle à vous si vous
êtes graphiste n'hésitez pas à me dire
si vous l'avez essayé ce que vous en
pensez ce stylet est ce que vous pensez
qu'il est effectivement bon pour toutes
les personnes qui veulent faire de
l'infographie du graphisme de la prise
de notes directement là dessus
maintenant on va parler un petit peu de
la partie du haut de l'écran supérieur
et je suis en intérieur franchement la
luminosité ok c'est bien évidemment un
écran complètement tactile
je peux venir naviguer directement ici
dans mon windows choisir ce que veut
faire ce que je veux donc ça c'est cool
on va s'ouvrir un petit pagne 3d mais
pour faire un petit peu de dessin là de
la même manière je vais pouvoir utiliser
mon style est utilisée directement sur
l'écran du haut
vous allez voir en acheter signe aussi
bien rouge et c'est aussi bien en haut
qu'en bas
la jument vraiment les fonctions
basiques déclare encore plus de choses
combinez le travail en deux entre les
deux écrans l'écran est vraiment cool
aussi pour me regarder des vidéos faire
du multimédia
je trouve que ça fonctionne super super
super super bien on a du dolby atmos
vous avez un haut-parleur ici sur le
côté vous avez un deuxième haut parleur
l'a alors ça marche très bien aussi
je vais lui poser directement me de
larmes tablettes ça marche bien hélas
pour le court terme à verrouiller cette
partie là et si je vais à déverrouiller
sa déverrouille cette partie je continue
à venir écrire là hélas que vous
regardez une vidéo complètement imaginer
un usage mixte
moi par exemple qui regarde la vidéo de
mon côté et puis ce n'est mon fils qui
dessinent de l'autre côté où quelqu'un
en face qui va créer bon je sais pas si
t'as pratique parce que ça risque de
bouger à terre en tout cas c'est
possible et ça franchement c'est hyper
cool bon le duo est cool fonctionne bien
il n'y a pas non plus énormément de
puissance non pas s'attendre à ce que le
yoga book développe une puissance de
dingue avec un spectre de ouf pas
manquer forcément un petit peu de basses
le sont néanmoins et franchement cool il
y à du dolby atmos dessus je trouve que
pour le petit format qu'on est dans la
taille des haut parleurs qui est
franchement réduite sept chiots gay book
de 2018 c'est vraiment un excellent
hambourg est fausse a franchement cool
donc si on doit faire un petit résumé
pour l'instant ce qu'on a vu les yogis
sexé un un ordinateur classique avec un
petit clavier même si c'est pas un
clavier physique mais vous avez le
retour haptique ça ça marche bien deux
c'est une tablette graphique pour venir
faire des dessins directement
dessus ou directement sur l'écran avec
le style et ça marche super bien
3 pour la prise de notes ça va aussi
très très bien pour des usages pro pour
venir travailler sur un document venir
griffonner des choses leur envoyais
modifié corriger rapidement ça marche
super bien
quatrième point pour une liseuse lors
que vous voulez bouquiner intrus que
sambou cramer les yeux le format votre
fille saute dans un train ce que vous
voulez vous qu'il est tout simplement un
format pdf ça marche très bien soit pour
une nautiques soit pour un livre ça
marche super bien
cinquièmement pour du multimédia pour me
regarder des vidéos en mode tablette
comme celle là ça marche aussi
merveilleusement bien c'est pas un deux
en un c'est 1,50 voire un peu plus
je sens qu'on peut retrouver plein
d'autres fonctionnalités tellement c'est
un gamin est complètement adaptable
adaptative par rapport aux différents
besoins aux différents usages et en plus
ce qui est vraiment cool c'est que c'est
vraiment un format qui est tout petit
qui est sécurisé avec un capteur
d'empreintes digitales il ya windows et
l'eau qui est là pour vous aider
alors je trouve qu'elle lala de souiller
la batterie qui se situe à mon avis par
ici tendance un petit peu à chauffer sa
crème pas c'est pas c'est pas hyper
chaud je semble que de chaleur ici là
vraiment c'est localisé c'est ici c'est
pas non plus surprenant la charnière est
extrêmement robuste très résistante
c'était pareil l'année dernière sur ya
deux ans en 2016 sur le yoga boucle j'ai
testé en 2017 nous pour moi en tout cas
de l'usaj que j'en ai eu du test que
j'en ai fait je trouve que c'est
vraiment un excellent produit je peux
que vous inviter
si vous recherchez ce jeu je tomberais
tient pas en place
si vous cherchez ce genre de format
c'est vraiment une très très belle
alternative entre un pc parce que c'est
un petit format malgré tout c'est un
écran 10,1 pouces est un petit peu le
point de regret dessus c'est un format
vraiment entre un pc entre une tablette
mais c'est pas une tablette pour moi
c'est beaucoup plus qu'une tablette
il n'ya pas d'android dessus on a
vraiment windows disent vous avez un
vrai beau clavier vous avez avoué
nos styles et c'est vraiment
d'ultraportables que vous pouvez emmener
partout avec vous et que je trouve
vraiment top et je ne peux que vous
recommander vous venez poser votre style
et là vous avez qu à vous balader faites
ce que vous voulez je trouve vraiment
coupe
dites moi ce que vous en pensez est-ce
que vous avez déjà testé la yoga bouc
nain précédents modèles de lenovo
et qu'est ce que vous pensez par rapport
à ce modèle là si c'est pas le cas et si
vous décidez fait beaucoup de prise de
notes est ce que ce modèle pourrait vous
intéresser en tout cas moi si c'est
vraiment quelque chose comme ça que vous
recherchez je peux vraiment vous le
recommander parce que je trouve vraiment
bien robuste de bonne qualité voilà
c'est tout pour cette occasion comme dit
moi plus que vous voulez en bas en
commentaire si vous avez des avis des
critiques des avis des suggestions de
tout ce que vous voulez vous pouvez y
aller je donne rendez-vous hyper
rapidement et puis je vous embrasse
soyez sages prenez soin de vous et puis
moi je vais aller m'entraîner à dessiner
autre chose que des morpions des coucous
parce que franchement je suis
extrêmement mauvais là dessus comme ça
la prochaine fois pour un prochain test
eh bien vous déciderez des choses
beaucoup plus joli voilà soyez sages et
à très bientôt prenez soin de vous une
chouette ça au cha